[Musik]
peter steiner adil der major
michael otto dennis j
sie sind die wohl bekanntesten deutschen
politischen gefangenen in der türkei sie
und viele andere deutsche gerieten ins
visier der türkischen justiz und des
türkischen präsidenten
ein terror agent der behauptet er
journalist den wollen sie von mir haben
bis heute sitzen zahlreiche deutsche in
türkischer haft oder dürfen das land
nicht verlassen viele aus politischen
gründen opfer eines präsidenten der
seine gegner gnadenlos verfolgt
[Musik]
von drei dieser gefangenen erzählt
dieser film drei frauen die jahrelang in
der türkei festgehalten wurden was haben
sie durchgemacht wie hat sich ihr leben
verändert
es sind die journalistin michelle idole
aus neu-ulm inhaftiert in istanbul ende
april 2017 ich glaube dass alles
politisch motiviert war und auch
politisch entschieden wurde aber all das
erlebte macht mich einfach wütend
die deutsch kurdische sängerin suzan
djane inhaftierten edirne im juni 2018
die türkei ist kein rechtsstaat es gibt
dort keine gerechtigkeit alles wird
hinter verschlossenen türen verhandelt
tochter goneril als
sozialwissenschaftlerin aus köln
festgenommen in istanbul im mai 2009 10
wie kann man einem menschen sowas antun
dass man zwei jahre an die seite eines
menschen einfach aus dem leben
wegradiert
allen drei wird mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation oder terror
propaganda vorgeworfen
sie werden festgehalten in einem land in
dem richter politische urteile fällen im
sinne des präsidenten in dessen kampf
gegen seine kritiker auch in deutschland
wie konnte es dazu kommen
es beginnt in der nacht des 15 juli 2016
in der türkei scheiterte putschversuch
einiger militärs gegen das regime von
präsident recep tayyip erdogan es gibt
viele tote
erdogan macht seinen politischen
gegenspieler den islam prediger
fethullah gülen und dessen anhänger für
den putschversuch verantwortlich und der
schwört erbitterte rache
wir werden dieses virus das sich in
allen staatlichen institutionen
verbreitet hat ausmerzen
sofort beginnt eine säuberungswelle die
bis heute anhält
zehntausende soldaten lehrer aber auch
staatsanwälte und richter die der gülen
sekte nahe stehen sollen werden
verhaftet oder entlassen werden ersetzt
durch unerfahrene und regierungstreue
beamte
der deutsche diplomat martin erdmann war
zur zeit des putschversuchs botschafter
in der türkei in diese zeit fällt auch
die inhaftierung der meisten deutschen
politischen gefangenen
das deutsch türkische verhältnis ist auf
einem tiefpunkt
ist insgesamt von der politischen seite
eine atmosphäre geschaffen in der
richter oder staatsanwälte glauben so
oder so handeln zu müssen auch das ist
teil der politisierung des systems
inhaftierte ausländer werden in einigen
fällen ganz offen als politische geiseln
benutzt beispiel der amerikanische
geistliche andrew brantzen erdogan will
ihn gegen den islam prediger fethullah
gülen austauschen für ihn der
drahtzieher des putschversuchs gülen
lebt im exil in den usa
belgier amerikaner hab doch auch einen
prediger bei uns gebt uns unseren
prediger und wir geben euch euren
positive zyniker haben nachdem der
präsident diese erklärung abgegeben hat
von den politischen gefangenen als von
menschlicher handelsware gesprochen
nämlich personen werden festgehalten um
politisch erpressen zu können
und
diese fälle
gab es auch
neben amerikanern franzosen briten
werden auch deutsche festgehalten der
prominenteste von ihnen ist der deutsche
journalist der zeitung die welt des
youtube
einen monat lang hat sich diese person
die ein vertreter der pkk und ein
deutscher agent ist im konsulat
versteckt einen monat lang wir haben
ihnen gesagt liefert ihn uns aus damit
wir ihn zur rechenschaft ziehen können
was auch immer passiert ist sie haben
ihn uns später ausgeliefert und unsere
justiz hat das notwendige getan und ihn
festgenommen
auf keinen fall wird er freikommen
solange ich hier auf diesen posten
setzte
war auch user eine solche menschliche
handelsware martin erdmann sagt für ihn
und die anderen sei nie ein preis
genannt wurden und doch sind sie
spielball der macht für den türkischen
präsidenten der seine gegenspieler
loswerden und sich als führer einer
starken und unabhängigen türkei
präsentieren will und der forderungen an
europa hat geld für syrische flüchtlinge
visaerleichterungen für seine türkischen
landsleute und eine zollunion
anfang 2018 empfängt der damalige
deutsche außenminister gabriel seinen
türkischen amtskollegen davutoglu zum
tee
wenige wochen nach diesem umstrittenen
treffen kommt denn des uk auf freien fuß
er sagt er wolle nicht gegenstand eines
deals sein doch die türkei will ihn
loswerden
es ist so dass die freilassung
stattfanden war die inhaftierungen zu
einer zu großen belastung
geworden war weil in deutschland
medien permanent berichteten über diese
verhaftung inhaftierung weil es diese
solidaritätskundgebung gab und insgesamt
die türkei in ein immer schlechteres
licht rückte und diese dieses image
problem
dass man erkannt hat das sollte
beseitigt werden durch die dann
plötzlich frei lassen wollte einfach ein
problem das man selber geschaffen hat
wieder ab
deutsche forderungen nach einer
freilassung der politischen gefangenen
werden als einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten abgekanzelt botschafter
erdmann wird regelmäßig zum rapport ins
außenministerium in ankara bestellt
während seiner fünfjährigen amtszeit
insgesamt 28 mal nach meiner
einschätzung waren meine einbestellung
oftmals instrument für die innenpolitik
man wollte den bürgern in der türkei
zeigen dass man diesen deutschland auch
die leviten lesen kann
ein zeichen nach innen an das eigene
wahlvolk oder an alle oppositionellen zu
hause und im ausland
es gibt leute die in deutschland an
kundgebungen einer terror-organisation
teilnehmen und dann in die türkei kommen
um urlaub zu machen
für die haben wir jetzt maßnahmen
getroffen die werden bei der einreise
festgenommen und ab geht's medien
und so lehmann soll hat damit erreicht
das heute tatsächlich weniger menschen
auch hier auf die straße gehen weil sie
eben familie türkei haben und um diese
familienmitglieder bangen oder fürchten
müssen wenn sie hier sich betätigen
[Musik]
im juni 2018 wird die kurdisch deutsche
sängerin suzan djane in edirne in der
westtürkei festgenommen
kurz vor der präsidentschaftswahl war
sie im wahlkampf für die pro kurdische
oppositionspartei hdp aufgetreten sie
wird dem haftrichter vorgeführt der
vorwurf mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation
sie soll kontakte zur pkk haben es ist
der beginn einer über dreijährigen
odyssee
von djane ist heute wieder zurück in
deutschland sie hat über ihre zeit in
der türkischen haft tagebuch geführt
arbeitet mit ihrer tochter und einem
freund an einem buch sie erinnert sich
an den tag als sie in das gefängnis in
edirne gebracht wurde und an den horror
den sie dort erlebt
als ich ins gefängnis von ema kam wusste
ich nicht dass es so schlimm sein würde
dass sie mich so behandeln würden es
kamen drei wörter und brachten mich in
eine kleine zelle sie zogen mich aus
einer packte meinen rechten arm der
andere den linken und erhielt meinen
kopf
der dritte kniete sich vor mich hin
hielt mit einer hand meinen rücken und
drang mit der anderen tief in mich ein
bis in die gebärmutter
ich habe geschrien und geweint
warum tust du das habe ich gebraucht ich
habe angefangen zu bluten und er meinte
vielleicht hast du ja heroin dort
versteckt
ihre tochter günel die landes erfährt
von der festnahme zu hause in köln
einmal in der woche dürfen mutter und
tochter miteinander telefonieren
das war die schlimmste zeit die zeit im
gefängnis in dem vor allem der einem
monat als ich in einzelhaft saß ich bin
fast verhungert und verdurstet
es war ein ort an dem gefoltert wurde
ich habe die schreie gehört
psychisch ging es mir gar nicht gut ich
dachte es wäre das beste zu sterben aber
der deutsche konsul hat mich davon
abgehalten
gönül setzt sich in deutschland
öffentlich für die freilassung ihrer
mutter ein als es ein genie im gefängnis
gesundheitlich immer schlechter geht
beschließt sie in die türkei zu reisen
und die mutter zu besuchen obwohl sie
das risiko kennt
die haben schon einen aus der familie
quasi und dann denkt man sich auch
kennen die tochter werden sie
wahrscheinlich nicht nehmen nur weil ich
die tochter dann kann ja nicht sein also
so brinkmann das ist echt viele firmen
jetzt auch wenn sie sich diesen beitrag
anhören werden sagen wie naiv muss man
dann sein aber in dem moment
weg man einfach ab was ist dann wichtig
so fliegt sie in die türkei landet auf
dem flughafen von istanbul und wird
gleich bei der einreise festgenommen
bei der passkontrolle haben sie gesagt
kommen sie mit das system zeigt in den
haftbefehl gegen sie wurde dann von
einem weiblichen mitgenommen in einem
raum separat und dann wurde mir gesagt
das ist eine schändung mitglieder einer
terrororganisation
ein vorwurf den sie sich nicht erklären
kann am nächsten tag wird sie dem
haftrichter vorgeführt
meine anwälte akteneinsicht angefordert
das wurde auch per fax geschickt und
erst dann habe ich hab ich gesehen
h20 12 k das verfahren ist eingestellt
was folge hat
dann der schock es war echt ein schock
meines lebens er es kann es sein
im jahr 2012 hatte sie an einer
protestaktion auf einem ausflugsdampfer
in köln teilgenommen neun aktivisten
forderten die freilassung kurdischer
hungerstreikende in der türkei das
verfahren gegen gönnen wird von der
staatsanwaltschaft köln eingestellt doch
jahre später tauchen die kölner akten in
ankara auf und seit 20 wirklich x-fach
in der türkei angereist es ist nichts
passiert warum
daran liegen dass ich einfach in den
letzten monaten für meine mutter viel
vor der presse stand wahrscheinlich dass
sie dann einfach recherchiert haben und
dann diese akte heraus genommen
eine harmlose demo in köln wurde die nun
zum verhängnis denn erdogan
staatsanwälte und richter verfolgen in
der türkei solche protestaktionen als
verbrechen selbst wer kritische tweets
teilt muss mit harten strafen rechnen
und erst recht jemand der für
oppositionelle medien arbeitet wie mesut
toll nach dem studium kommt sie 2014 in
die türkei verdient sich etwas nebenbei
als übersetzerin für die linke
nachrichtenagentur apa dass sie selbst
zum ziel von terrorermittlungen werden
könnte kommt ihr damals nicht in den
sinn
ich wurde in dieser zeit einfach
mitgerissen soll ich mal ich wurde nicht
man hat sich nicht ausgesucht mit schale
tolo zu inhaftieren sondern man hat
aktien ausgeübt gegen in die freie
presse und hat da eben auch mich
mitgenommen
und all das hat mein leben verändert der
türkei
wir haben sie bereits 2018 in ihrer
istanbuler wohnung besucht sie lebt dort
mit ihrer mannschaft und dem kleinen
sohn michael otto los schildert uns die
ereignisse jener nacht als um vier uhr
morgens ein anti terror kommando die
wohnung stürmt in der sie und ihr damals
zweijähriger sohn schlafen ihr mann
stewart saß da bereits wegen
terrorverdacht sind haft
die sind hier reingekommen und habe mich
direkt auf diesem boden gegenüber der
küche
hingeknallt
ich lag hier auf dem boden mit dutzenden
männern die auf mir drauf aufstanden und
mein sohn ist vom zimmer gegenüber
rausgerannt weinend rausgerannt weil ein
spezialeinheit kommando mit
maschinengewehr im dunklen sind
maschinengewehr auf ihn gerichtet hatte
über viele stunden muss sie mit ansehen
wie sicherheitskräfte ihre wohnung auf
den kopf stellen sie muss ihren
zweijährigen sohn bei nachbarn
zurücklassen und wird mitgenommen
das was mich am meisten geprägt aber
auch traumatisiert hat war
wahrscheinlich die polizei haft auf der
landstraße das ist bekannt als
folterzentrum aus den 80er 90er jahren
ich wurde ständig bedroht beängstigt
sollte ich werden oder auch
eingeschüchtert ich wurde illegal
verhört ohne dass meine anwälte darüber
informiert wurden ich kann nur sagen
dass das sie alle register gezogen haben
um mich zu brechen in dieser haftzeit
[Musik]
nach einigen tagen in der polizeihaft
wird michael otto lu ins frauengefängnis
nach bacchiocchi verlegt
eine anwältin ist zu mir gekommen und
hat mir berichtet dass es meinem sohn
sehr schlecht geht
dass er kann nicht mehr schläft dass er
träumt schlecht träumt dass er seine
milch nicht trinkt dass er sich die
schuld dafür gibt dass ich weg bin das
ist ja unruhig geworden ist dass er
sport hat und als ich das mitbekommen
habe war das einfach für mich
der ausschlaggebende punkt zu sagen mein
sohn muss bei mir sein egal wie schlecht
es uns drin geht
schlecht als ohne mama kann es ihm nicht
gehen
der sohn darf zu seiner mutter ins
gefängnis er wird sechs monate mit
michael hinter gittern verbringen doch
das frauengefängnis ist kein ort für
kinder
im gefängnis also tatsächlich hatten wir
nichts als vierter reingekommen sind und
haben uns aber eine ganz große bunte
welt zusammen erfunden darin unseren
gedanken freien lauf gelassen damit
unser sohn da drin einfach besser
zurechtkommt
gleichzeitig versucht sie sich gegen den
vorwurf der terror unterstützung zu
wehren doch regierungstreue türkische
medien haben ihr urteil bereits gefällt
es wurde geschrieben terroristen agentin
und wie kann man das alles wieder legen
wenn man eingesperrt ist und keine
stimme mehr hat wie kann ich eine fertig
geschriebenen geschichte umdrehen und
beweisen dass es gar nicht so wahr wenn
ich die mittel nicht dazu habe
sie beschließt zu kämpfen und an die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen familie und
freunde organisieren protestaktionen
michaletos wird neben deniz yücel und
peter steiner zur bekanntesten
politischen gefangenen in der türkei und
damit zum problem für beide seiten die
türkei und deutschland hinter den
kulissen wird verhandelt es gab immer
wieder auch presseberichte zum beispiel
auch den besuch altkanzler schröder
das ist ja publik geworden also das kann
glaube ich niemand abstreiten dass es
zwischen der türkei und zwischen
deutschland diplomatische gespräche über
unsere freilassung gab aber über deals
ob steals gab es also ich denke nicht
dass
das das bundesregierung auf solche
sachen eingegangen ist
und wenn würde ich auch sagen dass es
keiner von uns wahrscheinlich gewollt
hätte
die gespräche haben scheinbar erfolg
michaels vater jubelt nach knapp acht
monaten soll seine tochter aus der
untersuchungshaft entlassen werden doch
offenbar gibt es kräfte denen diese
gerichtsentscheidung nicht gefällt
ja das war wie ein kriminalfall
kriminalist ein auto angefahren ein
silbernes auto
mit dunklen fenstern und ich wurde dann
eben in diesem auto
durch die masse hindurch entführt aus
dem gefängnis
und es kreuzt dann am späten nachmittag
bis den abend hindurch eine
verfolgungsjagd ein
ein konvoi von botschafts fahrzeugen und
kamerateams rats durch istanbul niemand
weiß wo sich michael otto auf feld und
warum sie sich noch in polizeigewahrsam
befindet
schließlich fanden wir sie nach mehreren
nach ihren stopps in verschiedensten
polizeistationen in einer kleinen
polizeistation im zentrum von istanbul
dort war sie festgesetzt worden
also braucht solo ist hier
das wissen wir wir wissen nicht was ihr
zum vorwurf gemacht wird und warum sie
jetzt hier festgehalten wird das
versuche ich jetzt raus zu legen ich bin
dann in diese polizeistation hinein
gegangen und habe erklärt
ich werde diese polizeistation nur
verlassen in begleitung von matschiner
tolo sonst bleibe ich hier
schließlich kommt die deutsche noch in
der nacht frei sie hat eine
ausreisesperre darf die türkei nicht
verlassen muss sich regelmäßig bei der
polizei
ich glaube auch dass eine methode ist
menschen die auf freien fuß sind nochmal
einzuschüchtern bevor man sie in die
freiheit entlässt
es war quasi so eine andeutung auch wenn
du frei bist können wir nicht jederzeit
wieder nehmen entführen irgendwo
absetzen und keiner bekommt es mit
auch gönül die lars sitzt in der türkei
fest nach ihrer verhaftung am flughafen
von istanbul wird sie zunächst wieder
auf freien fuß gesetzt aber auch sie
wird mit einer ausreisesperre belegt
sie weiß nicht wo sie bleiben wie sie
ihren aufenthalt in der türkei
finanzieren soll sie hat verpflichtungen
in köln betreibt dort eine
sozialberatungsstelle der die schließung
droht die existenz als bürger in
deutschland ist gefährdet denn man hat
kein einkommen mehr man darf nicht seine
persönlichen dinge regeln soll man muss
den menschen finden die das für einen
tun ist et cetera es ist also eine
ausreisesperre kommt letztlich in ihrer
auswirkung einer inhaftierung gleich ich
habe graue haare bekommen damals hatte
ich keine graue haare ich hatte keinen
einzigen graue haar und ich habe auf
einmal eines tages ins springen geschaut
hat überall graue haare
da wurde mir bewusst mein gott es dieses
land bringt dich um wenn ich im
gefängnis dann draußen psychisch
du wirst sterben vor angst
ja dann habe ich einfach ein bisschen
recherchiert und ja in der türkei ist es
tatsächlich sehr sehr leicht an
irgendwelchen schlössern zu kommen
nach knapp vier monaten zwangsaufenthalt
in der türkei versucht sie mit hilfe von
schleppern den grenzfluss evros nach
griechenland zu überqueren doch der
fluchtversuch scheiterte sie wird von
türkischen sicherheitskräften
festgenommen und ins nahe gelegene
gefängnis von edler überstellt
es ist einer der schlimmsten gefängnisse
dies wahrscheinlich gibt danach würde
ich dann das war ja über eine gefängnis
danach wurde ich nach gäste und als ich
in gänze ankam
dann bin ich auch eine politische zelle
dann untergebracht man bei der kutschen
frauenpolitischen coaching frauen und
dabei pro weil es endlich warmes wasser
gab
und ich konnte endlich es gab im
vorgarten
garten wenn ich da so das ist kein
garten das ist einfach ein
hof aus vier wänden die ganze woche sind
das war denn doch nicht so wir waren 23
stunden in der zelle zwölf frauen in
einem raum für sechs betten das heißt
sie haben auch zusammen geschlafen in
einem weltklasse und ich war dann
einfach froh einfach frei atmen zu
können und dann mehr richtungen einfach
mich auf diesem hof auf der anderen hof
aufhalten konnte ja also das war das
schlimmste seite des gefängnis aber ich
habe das gut an gestecken können weil
ich vorher der bewusstsein war ja da du
hast jetzt versucht nach hause zu gehen
und um sowas gehalten ich konnte damit
klarkommen das war für mich okay aber
die zeit im hause ist
das ist davon habe ich mir noch
albträume
[Musik]
nach knapp drei monaten in haft wird gül
im dezember 2019 schließlich in den
hausarrest überstellt
wir dürfen sie dort besuchen sind
unterwegs mit celik genuss anwältin
wir müssen uns verpflichten die bilder
die wir dort drehen werden nicht zu
senden so lange sich gül in der türkei
aufhält denn im hausarrest gelten
ähnliche regeln wie in haft besuch ist
erlaubt kameras nicht
sie lebt in der wohnung eines onkels und
seiner familie darf das haus nicht
verlassen
trägt eine elektronische fussfessel
24 muss es drum bleib ich darf auch
nicht irgendwie versuchen das zu
schädigen weil das dann ein signal
aussendet anscheinend haben die mir
gesagt
ich muss damit duschen damit ins bett
gehen kein schönes gefühl also da fühlt
man sich tatsächlich wie ein
schwerverbrecher also ist es tatsächlich
zu tun ist ich lebe seit 25 jahren in
deutschland
studiert
eigene
arbeitswelt geschaffen wohnung gehabt
freunde gehabt
freund gehabt
familie
ist es weg
komplett weg also
klar
ich kann auch die manchen bestehen die
die angst haben um mir briefe schreiben
oder ich kann für menschen bestehe
die angst haben mich anzurufen
wir halten man hat schon alles verloren
jede geschichte hat auch ein ende auch
wiesen happy end ist oder traurige ende
ist aber es hat ein ende und ich glaube
nun daran dass die sich jetzt irgendwann
mal zu ende gehen wird also die
situation was ich hier durch machen
nur die zeit weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
ihr martyrium hält gönül anfangs vor
ihrer mutter verborgen um sie nicht zu
beunruhigen erst nach vielen monaten
erfährt von djane vom schicksal ihrer
tochter sie erinnert sich
[Musik]
ich wusste nichts davon dass meine
tochter nachdem sie in die türkei
gekommen war vier monate in haft saß und
danach nicht ausreisen durfte das haben
sie mir verschwiegen
als dann der anwalt irgendwann kam und
es mir erzählte habe ich fast den
verstand verloren
ihre
situation
ist irgendeiner weise
weniger
wichtig als meine situation
das ging ja viele menschen die auf
seinen jungs sehr politische gefahren so
frei sie einfach dahin führen krieg die
mutter besuchen bisschen befand mich ja
je nachdem mit tante
hinfliegt mein onkel
wir verlassen eine gebrochene frau
wenige wochen nach unserem besuch
beschließt gerne sich umzubringen will
sich vom balkon stürzen
[Musik]
märz glaube da konnte ich nicht mehr
weil ein bisschen zeit bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt kannte sehen ich auch nicht
mehr konnte
gab immer noch keine anklageschrift also
wenn man psychisch nicht stark ist und
weil ich stark da war natürlich alles
ein ende setzen da bist ok meine
gewinnabschöpfung abgehalten es hat sich
eine toilette gesperrt angespannt und
nach halbe stunde später kam auch die
consolar in
der model eines kollegen aus deutschland
eingeschaltet mit der ich am telefon
reden konnte habe ich einfach alles raus
gelassen ich wusste natürlich dass das
konsulat für mich immer da ist mit jedem
vergangen und tag verliert man die
hoffnung
[Musik]
nach monaten des wartens beginnt
schließlich ihr prozess will darf den
hausarrest in manisa für 24 stunden
verlassen es ist das erste mal seit
einem halben jahr dass sie sich wieder
frei bewegen kann sie darf persönlich
bei der verhandlung dabei sein reist
nach istanbul
am abend vor dem gerichtstermin
trainiert sie mit ihrer anwältin den
auftritt vor dem richter
der vorfall über den wir sprechen
ereignete sich im jahr 2012 also vor
mehr als acht jahren
du solltest nicht so hart sprechen bitte
sondern etwas ruhiger
bin ich nicht ruhig ok
[Musik]
das thema über das wir sprechen ist ein
ereignis das acht jahre zurückliegt wie
sie sagten im jahr 2012 da fällt es mir
schwer mich noch an alles genau zu
erinnern
wenn sie jetzt an der aktion beteiligt
oder nicht es ist mir gar nicht möglich
mich an einer solchen terroristischen
aktion zu beteiligen
ich gehöre keiner terrororganisation an
und unterstütze dieser auch nicht
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen die verhandlung
presse und botschaftsvertreter sind im
gerichtssaal anwesend die anhörung
dauert nur 15 minuten alles wirkt
inszeniert
und tatsächlich der hausarrest wird
aufgehoben
ich lasse es zwar immer noch nicht
darunter stand
[Gelächter]
das ding ist jetzt endlich nach fast
sieben monaten
ich werde das jetzt ich muss jetzt noch
nicht spielen und systeme das
zurückgeben aber es sind
ja keine
frage das ist gut aber klar die freude
war von kurzer dauer weil irgendwann mal
gast denn dieser stress oder seelischer
druck kommt ja
es wird an einem bewusst du kannst immer
noch nicht aus diesem band raus du bist
immer noch her gefahren nur der der der
umkreis ein bisschen vergrößert
die politischen gefangenen sind nach wie
vor eine belastung im deutsch türkischen
verhältnis doch beide länder bemühen
sich um eine verbesserung der
beziehungen zu wichtig sind die
gegenseitigen wirtschaftlichen und
sicherheitspolitischen interessen das
verhältnis entspannt sich und das hat
offenbar auch auswirkungen auf die lage
der politischen gefangenen
in das verfahren gegen harnik kommt
plötzlich bewegung
obwohl das gericht kurz vorher
entschieden hatte dass sie in haft
bleiben muss wird goethes mutter ende
september 2020 unerwartet aus dem
gefängnis entlassen
wie kann das sein
in einem rechtsstaat war sind wir nicht
das ist schon mal klar aber trotzdem ein
gerichtsbeschluss das vor zehn tagen
gesagt soll im gefängnis bleiben und
nach zehn tagen ist sie dann freier
freiem fuß
stelle ich bis heute nicht
als ich sie das erste mal sah ging es
mir gesundheitlich nicht gut
ich hatte starke stiche im herzen
vielleicht war es aus freude ich weiß es
nicht aber
in diesem moment fühlte ich mich sehr
verloren
[Musik]
das war nicht meine mutter dich monaten
gesehen hätte
sie war
ausgehungert
ängstlich zwar nicht mehr meine mutter
die ich kannte ich habe innerlich
gefragt wer ist diese frau das ist nicht
meine mutter
wieder vereint mieten sich die beiden
frauen in istanbul eine kleine wohnung
und warten auf ihren nächsten
gerichtstermine das martyrium geht
weiter über viele lange monate
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als sie bemerkten dass ihre wohnung
überwacht wird verlassen sie istanbul
wohnen abwechselnd bei verschiedenen
verwandten und freunden
tunnels gerichtsprozess findet in
istanbul statt der ihrer mutter in
edirne drei autostunden entfernt
[Musik]
das ist eine politische entscheidung das
hat nichts mehr mit einem rechtsstaat zu
tun und bei politischen entscheidungen
gibt es immer ein auf und ab es kann
sich alles plötzlich ändern deshalb kann
es heute einen freispruch geben oder sie
stecken mich wieder ins gefängnis nein
quatsch na ja das weiß man nie
jedes mal die quälende ungewissheit wie
das gericht diesmal entscheiden wird
wieder dauerte die verhandlung nur
wenige minuten wieder war eine reise
umsonst wieder vertagt sich das gericht
diesmal um weitere vier monate
weil einfach kein normaler sondern ein
politischer fall ist bin ich nicht allzu
verärgert ich persönlich denke es gibt
ein problem zwischen den ländern das
über meinen kopf hinweg ausgetragen wird
ich fühle mich wie ein ping pong ball
den man hin und her schlägt und das
macht mich sehr traurig
genauso ergeht es auch michael otto nach
ihrer entlassung aus knapp achtmonatiger
untersuchungshaft lebt sie wieder in
istanbul die prozesse gegen sie und
ihren mann laufen weiter ziehen sich
über monate lange zeit bewegt sich
nichts
das heute immer noch nicht ausreisen
kann
habe ich wie gesagt erwartet weil ich
wusste von anfang an das alles sehr
politisch entschieden wurde und das ist
glaube ich heute auch zufall
ich musste immer wieder dokumente
einreichen
ich durfte das land nicht verlassen
und sobald ich irgendwie aus istanbul
irgendwohin gereist bin ist eine ganze
kolonne von polizisten hinterher gewesen
es war eine zeit in der ich mich noch
unsicherer als im gefängnis gefühlt habe
weil ich wusste dass die polizei immer
vor meiner tür ist dass die anti terror
einheit wieder zugreifen kann
[Musik]
acht monate verbringt die familie in
istanbul schließlich entscheidet der
richter dass die ausreisesperre
aufgehoben wird dass michael thon mit
ihrem sohn nach deutschland zurückkehren
darf
kurz darauf kann auch ihr mann sucht die
türkei verlassen
es hieß immer es gibt einen zeugen gegen
mich der über mich ausgesagt hat im
endeffekt hat mein anwalt bewiesen dass
es zu keinem zeitpunkt einen ominösen
zeugen gab der über mich ausgesagt hat
er ist dass es keine
ermittlungsverfahren jemals gegen mich
in der türkei gab und das nicht mal der
verdacht einer mitgliedschaft in einer
terroristischen organisation bewiesen
werden kann
für gönül die landes und ihre mutter
susanne sieht es dagegen nicht nach
einer baldigen ausreise aus im gegenteil
nach fast zwei jahren in der türkei
langen monaten vor gericht und trotz
einer dünnen beweislage fordert der
staatsanwalt für gönül überraschend 15
jahre haft
wenige tage später soll das urteil
fallen
und dann habe ich gesagt okay die
nächsten vier jahre will ich nicht ins
gefängnis zumindest nicht für das was
ich nicht getan habe
und dann habe ich nochmal meinen ganzen
mut zusammen gefasst hat gesagt es ist
mir wirklich egal wenn ich schon ins
gefängnis komme dann will ich diese eine
sache nicht und versucht gelassen habe
ich gehe vorher nach hause ich versuche
nach hause zu kommen
diesmal klappt es am tag vor dem
urteilsspruch gelingt ihr die flucht
nach griechenland
als am nächsten morgen das gericht tagt
lässt sie sich wegen krankheit
entschuldigen da ist sie schon längst in
deutschland wo wir sie damals
telefonisch erreichen bis heute ist sie
fassungslos über das harte
gerichtsurteil
schuldig zehn jahre und fünf monate haft
doch im gleichen atemzug wird die
ausreisesperre aufgehoben
tun alles um ihr gesicht zu bewahren
mein gott mit allen mitteln
man kann ich jemandem zehn jahren fünf
monate gefängnis strafen geben und dann
sagen gehen sie doch nach hause es ist
vorbei was ist vorbei ich bin verurteilt
und dann darf nach hause gehen in den
nächsten flugzeug einsteigen ab nach
hause
das muss man verstehen also ich hab ich
richtig voll tag immer noch nicht
deswegen schon darüber es ist
unverständlich
die frage nach dem sinn würde ich gar
nicht stellen das ergebnis zählt und das
ergebnis ist das feuer
auf freiem fuß ist und das land
verlassen konnte und in die deutsche
heimat zurückkehren konnte wie das
system mit diesem offensichtlichen
widerspruch umgeht das muss das system
selber erklären
[Musik]
ich kam nach hause natürlich ist wahr
ich war alleine und
ich habe
die tür aufgemacht und alles war richtig
von ab vor meiner abreise bei den marken
lassen hat sie es vertragen und ich
glaube weil ich weil die reise auch so
lange war ich
war so müde ich bin rein auf dem kopf
und am bein geschlafen am längsten ist
mir gekommen
in den nächsten monaten versucht sie an
ihr altes leben anzuknüpfen sie eröffnet
wieder ihre sozialberatungsstelle ein
freund hat sie ein zimmer in seinem büro
überlassen
das buch von mir die sünder vom
gefängnis und wisse also im gefängnis
habe ich auch nicht
still gesetzt
einen monat nach kohls rückkehr wird
überraschend auch die ausreisesperre
gegen ihre mutter aufgehoben nach drei
jahren den türkischer gefangenschaft ist
hosen djane wieder in köln
[Applaus]
die beiden frauen leben wieder zusammen
in der kölner wohnung oder ein genie ist
froh zurück in deutschland zu sein
sicher aber fühlt sie sich auch hier
nicht
die deutschen haben mich sehr
unterstützt die deutsche regierung hat
sich um mich gekümmert
trotzdem habe ich angst auch hier gibt
es viele türkische faschisten es kann
jederzeit wieder etwas passieren
gül erscheint die zeit in der türkei
manchmal wie ein schlechter traum
[Musik]
hat empfinde ich nicht aber
diese diese fassungslosigkeit und diese
enttäuschung wie kann man einem menschen
sowas antun dass man zwei jahre an die
zeit eines menschen einfach aus dem lean
back radiert in der zwischenzeit hätte
ich vielleicht tausend andere sachen
hier machen können ist mir alles
weggenommen worden
michael otto lebt heute mit ihrem mann
und ihrem sohn wieder im haus des vaters
in neu ulm nach vier jahren haft
ausreisesperre und prozessen in der
türkei beantragt der vertreter der
anklage schließlich freispruch wegen
mangel an beweisen
ich war sehr wütend als ich gehört habe
dass die staatsanwaltschaft für mich
freispruch beantragt ich habe ganz viele
traumata ich habe depressionen lebt ich
bin mit einem zweijährigen sohn
monatelang im gefängnis gewesen also
unter den widrigsten bedingungen habe
ich gelebt um dann zu hören dass ein
staatsanwalt sagt das war alles für
nichts
ein ziel hat der türkische präsident
erreicht so lange er an der macht ist
werden seine kritiker wie michael otto
jonel die lancia und all die anderen
keinen fuß mehr in die türkei setzen und
ihre geschichten sollen seinen gegnern
eine warnung sein ihr müsst wissen hier
die täter die angeblichen täter hier
muss wissen egal wo ihr seid
der arm der türkischen justiz ist lang
und irgendwann kriegen euch all das
spricht dafür dass sich die türkei kein
schritt gebessert hat sondern dass in
der türkei die repression sich
verstetigt hat zu meiner zeit waren
offiziellen neuen deutsche staatsbürger
in der türkei inhaftiert das war die
zahl die konsularischen mitarbeiter
damals mir mitgeteilt haben heute glaube
ich über 60
es sind dutzende deutsche die laut
auswärtigem amt auch heute noch in der
türkei festgehalten werden die in haft
sitzen oder mit ausreise sperren belegt
sind viele davon aus politischen gründen
ihre fälle machen keine schlagzeilen
doch sie teilen das schicksal der drei
frauen deren geschichten wir erzählt
haben sie alle sind opfer eines systems
das seine kritiker zu staatsfeinden
erklärt
[Musik]